that was like super hot
i haven't even gotten to this one yet
hey what's going on and happy
thanksgiving everybody for first week
feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by lil nas x
he's a two-time grammy award winner you
of course know from his breakout hits
panini and old town road one of the
biggest records in billboard history
his latest single however holiday is
available now
lil nazex happy thanksgiving and welcome
to the show
happy thanksgiving i'm happy to be here
on thanksgiving when you worked at
zaxby's did you ever reach for like the
tongue torch sauce or the nuclear
how are you with spice uh i never got
that far
i mean i i didn't even like spicy food
at first
you know i mean it's starting to grow on
me now but you don't want to make it
through this so
i guess i'm fine so yeah
so i'm just gonna bounce this onto my
wings huh that's how it'll go
no just eat it right and you just eat it
i feel super confident so as we
mentioned up top
you're releasing new music for the first
time since your grammy campaign last
year
and i get the sense that this upcoming
album two years in the making
means a little bit more to you as a full
body of work
how would you define success for this
next project
uh it's so much more personal and so
much more me
and less like characters i've created so
it's going to be so dope for everybody
to finally hear it and everybody's
already
[ __ ] with holiday right now so that's
dope too you know most importantly that
i love it if i love it
and everybody else loves it that's
amazing if i love it and everybody don't
then
you know that's cool as long as i love
it you know
that's kind of sweet it's all right it
kind of tastes like zack sauce because
you mentioned that i worked at zaxby's
kind of tastes like zack sauce
so there are a few things more first we
feast than little nazaks and gordon
ramsay making a panini and we are still
kicking ourselves to this day for not
brokering that cooking demo
did you pick up any cooking tips from
hanging out in the kitchen with chef
ramsay
uh yeah i feel like if you yell at
people more it's definitely gonna make
the food
taste amazing you know he was like
motivating me a lot you know saying
inspiring things
because you know he's done so much
already and you know i'm just getting
started on my journey
so you know still hear that from him
yeah
sequoia sauce interesting
pretty great
has that uh deep sort of curry vibe to
it
yeah i definitely can taste the curry
vibe so
during the limewire days one of the ways
that soulja boy got crank that off the
ground
is that he would label his song
something like michael jackson's
thriller
thus cloaking that song into
unsuspecting playlists all over the
internet
when you think about the creative
tactics that you've used to get your
music off the ground
is there a specific strategy you found
bizarrely effective
i guess it's always like having those
little parts in the songs
in the song that are like super
memorable or like little parts that are
like unexpected
that people can cling on to and like put
into
like a little [ __ ] tick tock or
something or having those little moments
in a video or something little
unexpected moments
you know i saw the lil yachty episode
that was pretty great yeah that was
classic
you know he never had hot sauce before
he uh
he did hot ones it was like really it
was like learning to run but like
starting by uh running the boston
marathon
yeah i kind of started starting to hit
out of nowhere
okay let's go
this is like this goat like why do they
make this goat so thick
that's amazing
is this barbecue sauce
it does have that barbecue vibe to it
smoky this is great
this is my favorite one so far so when
we had t-paint on the show
he put chowder in his list of all time
cartoon mount rushmore
what's the backstory and the meaning
behind the song panini because i
understand that it's not at all about a
sandwich
okay panini's like this character on
chowder right and like she's this
character that's obsessed with chowder
so my song quinine flips on that and
it's this character
who's once obsessed with me that doesn't
love me anymore because everybody loves
me now you know
your music video for rodeo has all kinds
of pop culture references from buffy the
vampire slayer to the matrix
do you have a favorite easter egg in
that video treatment
my favorite easter egg i like the
beginning part
where it's like this supposed to be like
this stream reference where it's like
somebody's calling this telephone in the
middle of nowhere and i'm going to get
it
uh and it's like ah in this high-pitched
voice
you'll see you guys got to go and watch
it click off of this and then come back
and then you know yeah okay
i shouldn't lick my lips huh yeah you
have to be kind of careful out here
all right little nasa we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham where we do a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story
first things first how did john mayer
make you cry
maybe he said something super
inspirational john mayer is like a super
cool dude he just likes
he just says cool [ __ ] you know like one
time he was at
who's that uh grunt perry's part he's
like the ceo of columbia
and then john mayer just like walks
walks near the pool and like
says something super cool and just walks
away you know it made me cry a little
bit
i know that this was a big moment for
you where does performing a duet with
elmo
rank on your list of 2020
accomplishments this is probably top two
and it's not too
elmo and he's also like super nice but
it was like i was surprised
there was like it was it wasn't actually
him talking it was like a guy with like
his
his hand up his back just wasn't what i
expected
[ __ ] you ready i'm ready
it made like a little hard before it
like moved
i know that face
i know that face
it's just good that's why i'm making
that face because it's good i like it
we've had a lot of guests who i would
say get the internet but as we've
touched on earlier i'm not sure i've
ever met anyone with your level of
aptitude
is there a specific country a specific
place a specific city that you
think is leading the charge when it
comes to pushing the boundaries of
creativity online
like where do you think the digital
cultural currency is coming from right
now
i feel like atlanta and new york
so i feel like i feel like that's where
all the culture comes from you know
where everything's pushing from me
personally
and i'm not being biased because i'm
from atlanta i just believe it you know
the internet can be such a dark place if
you've had a rough day
what's the closest thing that you can
find on the internet as to like a safe
refuge
i don't know sometimes like i'll go on
youtube and just watch a bunch of cat
videos and
stuff like that where cats are being
rescued or like a cat playing with the
dog or
you know stuff like that or you know
best case scenario i'll probably just
get off because
the internet is terrible if you want to
like you know if you're having a bad day
you probably don't want to be on the
internet you know
this one's very liquidy
okay there it is
nice that was cute
that was a cute one so you have an
offbeat sense of humor about yourself
and about life that reminds me quite a
bit of friends i've interviewed in the
past including joji and rich bryan
where the absurd and the real the lines
are so blurred that it's impossible to
distinguish one from the other
so if you'll humor me i want to play a
game called was it
a troll where i'll bounce some of your
more outrageous public statements off of
you
and you just tell me to what degree any
of them are true
yeah big sean famously leaked his own
phone number on the outro of dark sky
paradise
was that real or a troll when you
tweeted out your visa card information
that was definitely a trove or maybe it
was real maybe it's one of my cards that
i was no longer using
did you actually eat that floating
dinner in the bathtub with like the hot
dog on top of the
white bread yes that was my dinner and i
enjoyed that
yeah it was the big i had the big cookie
i had that had the hot link
and i had the hot chips right classic
it's like a classic meal you have to
love it
when you tweeted that you just heard
your song in a porn was that real or was
that a troll
that was real it was real someone sent
it to me it was like yo
your song is in this and it was like i
was like why are you watching that
specific thing
i won't get into the details of course
you ready i'm ready if you're
the bomb ready insanity
it's that time
hmm
rumble's your chest this one
i don't even taste it hotter than
anything they have at the zaxby's i
think
what do you think is the greatest cowboy
inspired fit that you got off at last
year's awards season
the pink the pink one at the grammys the
people that the grammys was great
what's the most impressive stunt that
you learned to do in all of your hours
riding horseback
a great one
i'm not going to drink anything
there are i don't think i learned any
cruel cool tricks for that
i did see you you were on the back of a
horse and it was like fully
up i think that qualifies i think that
qualifies as a stunt
that was dope i was dope
you're releasing a children's book c is
for country early next year
what's the connection you make between
the cowboy lifestyle and your own career
[ __ ] it's hot it's really hot okay
i get i understand i'm with you
completely i'm right here with you i'm
right here with you i understand
okay with my
with my career
and the cowboy uh ecstatic i guess it's
kind of like
how cowboys kind of like they don't
really give
like too too many [ __ ] about what other
people
are gonna say about what they're gonna
do or whatever you know
and it's like been my strong suit with
everything
especially like this year yeah you know
and just having to
be like super headstrong about that yeah
so that's it
you ready for the next wing i am
parker butt shout out pucker butt
that last one was pretty hot that was
like super
that was like super hot i haven't even
gotten to this one yet
you ready i'm ready
so i read that you took a college
computer science class with plans of
making the next
great app did you think it out any
further than that or come up with a name
i just i just want it to be like
it should be like the next main form of
social media you know
and who says i still won't you know
cry what was your most memorable
interaction when you made your
heroes return to your old high school
this last year
the best thing ever was like
like going through the halls and then
like everybody like chasing me down like
a like a [ __ ] cartoon or something
you know
like chip skye like oh if you know what
chip skylark is but it was like on this
failure parents show
uh but and i can like walk through the
halls
without like nobody saying anything you
know like
without getting in trouble about it you
know that was pretty dope
yeah those kids were very nice too
i'll dress this entire wing and eat it
all right if you're gonna do that
i'm gonna do that we will go out in just
flames here on the thanksgiving special
let's do it
you see it you're just covered too right
we're eating the whole thing
whoa i think i gotta go bigger
here you ready
all right this is it's a stark stream
this is crazy
all right oh hold on i can smell this
one
i can smell the spiciness on this one
doesn't matter you ready i'm ready i'm
ready
one two three
see there you go
all right little nasdaq here we are at
the conclusion of our fifth ever
thanksgiving day special and following
in the great tradition of guest pass
i think that we end things with a
full-blown rapid fire
and how to best celebrate the holiday
according to lil nasdaq's
it's hot no i know i know
very extreme move i'm just following you
off the cliff here
not that was nothing
one's gotta go sides edition
mac and cheese mashed potatoes cornbread
or stuffing
mashed potatoes
i need some more milk
make no apologies it is just a fireworks
display here
what a day to break in the holidays
that was wild
ah why is it still burning
well it's it was a lot of a very extreme
hot sauce
be careful with the milk though you know
like um drinking too much milk i don't
want it to like
upset your stomach just be careful every
every problem that we've ever had has
been a
more a milk problem than a sauce problem
why did you tell me to do that you told
me to do that
why did you convince me to do that
you convinced me to do that do you have
a go-to strain when it's time to take a
walk before dinner
oh my that's hilarious
yes my go-to strain is to read the bible
drugs are bad
pound for pound what do you think is the
best thanksgiving dessert
banana pudding i love banana pudding
who do you got tonight steelers or
ravens
ravens and then finally can you give me
one essential
lil nas x track for the dinner party
playlist
holiday i knew that you were gonna say
that holiday
stop the video go check out holiday come
back to the video
little nosex will still be suffering
from that last wing
just an absolutely outrageous and insane
exhibition when it comes to water and
milk consumption i've never seen
anything like it at all my life
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you on this
very special
thanksgiving day adventure this camera
or that camera
or whatever setup you have going on over
there let the people know what you have
going on in your life
hello everybody i'm lil nazex
and um go go scream holiday yay holidays
amazing amazing thanks man this is great
did you have a good time yeah of course
i'm not going to drink anything
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say
thank you so much for watching today's
episode and i have an exciting
announcement
a very exciting announcement feast your
eyes
on the hot ones reebok collab
i am so excited for this collaboration
you have the club c
you have the classic leather and of
course the shacknosis
now you can do the shack face in style
the way it was intended let me walk you
through my favorite features on each one
first off with the club c
i love that it's the color of milk on
the back
you have this cool hot ones logo with
the scoville scale and i love how the
reebok logo it's kind of like the lower
third that we put with
guests that is our mild our milk
and then up next we have the classic
leather it's our medium
it has the scoville scale along the side
i like the scoville scale on the tongue
it comes in at 198 300 scoville units
1983 the year the classic leather was
dropped
and that's what i love about these shoes
everything has such purpose
right down to the five wings on the
bottom of the sole
wear them both and you have a full hot
ones gauntlet
and finally the shacknosis classic
shacknosis shoe hot ones on the back
cranked all the way up to 11 just like
the shack episode
and then you have the scoville scale
colorway
different color laces the hot ones
reebok collab we are so so proud
reebok.com reebok.com reebok.com to get
your hands on the hot ones
reebok collab even the box has milk and
wings
all over it hot ones reebok
put them on your feet baby